- I know no, which is,
how do you say that again?
(accordion polka music)
- I know nothing about German.
- I think the German language
has some like, nuances
to it and has a nice flow to it.
- The only thing that I
remember is "bluder affen,"
I think it means funny monkey.
- [Voiceover] Arschkrampe.
- If it were like French, it
would be, "arsch krampay."
- Arschkramp.
- Arschkrampe.
- A dresser or some piece of furniture.
- I'm gonna say it's, pain in the ass.
You're being such an
arschkrampe, right now.
- [Voiceover] Arschloch.
- Arsch clock.
- Ash lock.
- Arschloch.
- That's gotta be asshole.
- Everyone's got an arschlock.
- [Voiceover] Babbsack.
- Babbsack.
- Babbsack means boobs.
- Condom face.
- Sounds like ball sack, to me.
- Oh, so I'm a babbsack.
Well, you haven't dated me.
- [Voiceover] Hannebampel.
- (laughter) Hanna, hannababble.
- Hannah bample.
- Hannebampel.
- Yeah, that's a fun word, hannebampel.
- You eat human flesh,
you're a hanburblepull.
- You can't emulate the same word.
- [Voiceover] Peniskopf.
- (laughter)
- Peniskoff.
- Peniskopf.
- I'm guessing that's
the German cock block,
you have peniskopf.
- Sounds like a diseased penis.
- Dick head.
- That's what I love
about the German language,
it's literally what it says.
- [Voiceover] Volltrottel.
- Voldemort?
- Volldorrel, it's
Voldemort's evil cousin.
- Vulltruttle.
- Volltrottel, boom.
- I want this to mean Voltron.
- Ugly bitch.
German's a great language to curse in.
- Uh, no, I can't do the accent
without making fun of people,
on accident.
(accordion polka music)